fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby I like looking at other
people's cars I don't even like Drive I
keep my [__] just I'm just chilling
bring that mic closer to you oh I drive
mine like I still gotta get it I put
miles on my cars dude miles yeah he does
he'll he'll buy like the best Ferrari
and just drive it like an everyday car
that's dope yeah right I drive it like
it's Grand Theft Auto yeah see I just
[__] I have so many and I buy them
all quick and I just barely have time
you know so I've just bought the new uh
720 I got a f8 about a um Phantom yeah
what else I buy recently what kind of
money you making about a Brabus uh g-wax
those are cool all the new ones those
are sick I want to get into the
motivational speakers
we're doing we're doing like a you know
like I'm trying to 100 a day Brian
drives the small soy boy Tesla yes I do
he's a Tesla guy I'm a Tesla guy so you
guys can [__] off okay now if I if I got
if I went to prison and on my paperwork
it said Tesla honor I get the [__] beat
out of me right well we don't need that
right
anyway what would they do no they'd
probably just be like [__] yeah this guy
had money because everyone they're so
damn broke they couldn't even have a
Tesla yeah no but um what else did I get
recently
the provinces are filthy right now did
you did you dream of all this stuff when
you were doing the 10 years I was a drug
dealer before I was a millionaire before
prison but I was selling [__] drug
like weed and Coke and [__] so I already
had like Range Rover I had like a condo
I had like a mini Mick Mansion but you
didn't own any of it right like that's
my thing with drug dealers like when you
look at it because you're not gonna
you're not paying taxes clearly I was I
was just watching through a construction
company
did you learn business through that or
you always had an instinct I just I mean
I just know how to [__] just uh
provide a service and collect a profit
you know I just always trying to get
that money but um this was different I
just wanted to be better like I was I
was happy I came out I wasn't a [__]
wreck anymore
because I assume a lot of guys when they
get out of there it's kind of tough to I
got out with 200 bucks and had to live
with my grandma again in the same room
as my parents that's uh so what was it
on a twin bed in the in the corner of
their [__] room so what when you're
in that situation you come out of jail
after 10 years are we started yeah yeah
okay you know we just we just go yeah
that's good [__] so you you come out of
you come out of prison
um 10 years you're living at your mom's
house yeah I was living at my grandma's
house in the same room as my [__]
parents on a twin bed in the corner they
had like no carpet on the floor dogs
like pissing and it's like dude they're
just they're still struggling like
they're still struggling like they were
before I went to prison normal uh
construction worker dad hairdresser mom
and they're just trying to make it and I
come out of prison I'm not [__]
helping I'm I dude they're just hoping
I'm not a liability like coming out
[__] straight Gangland like American
History X [__] they don't know
they don't know the difference of what
goes on in there but I come out and I'm
just super positive why and I because I
just had to change bro it was it made me
sick to my stomach the person I was how
many people I hurt like how much just
violence I did and it just you know just
we were still selling dope in prison too
and people were not making it from that
so I mean like we were still trying to
capitalize on other people's misfortunes
and I just saw that that was the problem
like you couldn't turn a negative into a
positive ever like some stripper isn't
gonna just strip her way into her
mansion and live her life happily ever
after bad money is bad money so like I
just I just correlated all this [__] in
my head I read books like Napoleon Hill
and other things that were like karmic
debt is being acquired by certain
actions and I just really started to
build like a real structured system and
core beliefs and core values around like
Universal truths that would govern me at
all times so that I wouldn't break to my
own desires because my own desires were
the problem always yeah did you try
preaching that in prison like being
positive like oh yeah but I was well I
was still hard as [__] though I'd be
like I'll beat the living dog [__] out
to you but I'll do it with a smile but
but I like I don't want to [__] be
this way anymore but I know I have to
but yeah like it I wasn't like a pre
I've never been a preacher about that
[__] I preach stuff like this on my
Instagram right now 10 minutes later if
someone [__] says something I'm like
you stupid [__] what the [__] your
problem I'm just me so you keep your
walls up but at the same time I mean
it's the same thing a discipline
dangerous [__] that's a real man
discipline and dangerous this dude you
should do a cauliflower cauliflower ears
like I ain't [__] with that
[__] but he's got discipline he
carries himself well he's not gonna be a
[__] wrecker he wouldn't be this
successful wearing a sub kicking it here
you know yeah so so when I'm sorry do
you what do you do he does trust me
you're completely transparent when when
you wake up or you come out of jail what
are the things do you talk to yourself a
certain way in the morning would you set
yourself up for success I set up
everything like nowadays when I work
with people yeah I set up their daily
actions the self-talking thoughts
they're having during those actions to
stick to the blueprint I build for them
so I built a blueprint for me where I
wake up at 2 45 every morning have for
over 15 years never missed once then I
go straight into like a quick reading
and reflective state where I just get my
mind right and get my aim for the day
and then I go directly I start preparing
and I go do my workout I'm at my workout
by 4 AM get that first workout done then
after that the rest of the day I'm
sticking to like real structured
macronutrients that I feel are like the
guidelines to Baseline discipline so I
always figure like when I break on my
diet or break on one of the disciplines
I had set for myself that I let myself
down you know because I made that like I
structured that plan for [__] me and
for myself so when I [__] up on
something that I said I was gonna do I'm
let down inside and what people don't
realize is when you let yourself down
you project that onto others so that's
what makes you have bad relationships a
bad a pessimistic view of the world and
it just said all like flawed perception
of everything around you because you're
[__] up so everything around you
looks [__] up yeah but when you're
killing it you're sticking your word
everything around you man catches that I
like to say the world is not as it is
the world is as you are so I mean what
you cultivate within shapes your
external environment in your world so if
you want to live a great life you have
to stick to one of the main things which
is letting regret be your guideline so a
lot of people are like I'm not trying to
be swole West I'm not trying to do all
this I'm like but when you hate that did
you regret it and they're like yeah and
I'm like well then that means you're
being called to not be that and so I'm
just going by this internal guidance
system which I call conscience
congruency and I'm just leveling in
everything that makes me feel really at
peace and hold because I've had money
before prison I have a lot of money now
and money doesn't do it for me I have to
feel good if I don't feel good I'm not
going to even be able to do this yeah
like I have to like cultivate what about
when you're in a situation like jail
where you have so little control we're a
group we have a lot of control in prison
you do of yourself but a group of guys
could say hey you got two years left in
your sentence go stab that guy and
you're gonna and they do and they do so
how do you deal with that [__] that type
of [__] is you just have to chalk it up
as to I I have to do this while I'm here
so I have that mindset if I'm going to
be the best at everything I do so
everyone went to prison I said I'm gonna
be the [__] best at prison so I got
covered in prison tats I stayed like 220
plus like veined up ripped cleaned up
yeah just clean diet I would I would
make people I would trade the snacks to
get people to go get me more protein I
would I'd slang in there do what I did
with white and black and green all this
[__] just to um just to make sure I had
enough protein powder and stuff like
that until I quit that even because I I
could tell that I was having people go
sweat their people on the street for
Green Dot numbers to pay and all that
[__] this is the way we pay money in
there get like money packs from 7-Eleven
and people give you uh numbers like a a
phone number type digit and like I'll
have a phone book full of like 500 Green
Dots that's where I had 30 50 000 in a
phone books yeah just for whatever [__]
I wanted I buy cell phones like nothing
anytime I hit the line I'll be like how
many phones are here I'll buy them all
on the Block and then rent them out to
everybody to where I'm just [__]
clocking you know I could make more
money in a [__] confined environment
than most people can make on the street
you know
Jesus Christ dude like I would be in the
shoe in the back Wireless but so that's
interesting because I always say that
about successful people you can take
really successful people and you can put
them in a [__] hole so that this guy
I know he he's made a lot of money and
so he and these all these dudes decided
to do Navy SEAL training but they wanted
to do like real hell week
so there's just casual they're they're
all yeah they just want to go through
corporate guys okay so so all of them
are corporate guys send some of them to
triathlons and stuff like that and there
were three dudes that were left and I
saw a picture of the three dudes and one
of the guys was this big he had love
handles he was kind of like you know
kind of just didn't look like an athlete
at all and I said that guy made it and
he goes yeah that guy made it he's a
billionaire and I've never seen a mind
stronger wasn't an athlete wasn't
anything but he was one of those guys
who could just [__] find a way to be
mind over matter no matter what and it's
like that's an interesting thing to me
like you can take people who who are
successful and it really is a mindset oh
100 I mean it's it's it's habitual
construction so I mean you habitually
construct a different mindset around
what you're doing so it you either find
excuses or find a way and most people
find an excuse so then that's just who
they become like they end up just always
opting out and I wrote a book called
non-negotiable
um do it 10 years incarcerated building
the unbreakable mindset so I wrote a
book about that everything I do is
non-negotiable so that's the Cornerstone
of My Success I won't negotiate on my
wake-up time it's all very simple [__]
maybe let's take a little break I'll be
in Springfield Missouri this Friday
Saturday blue Comedy Room buddy blue
comedy now they have the biggest uh Bass
Pro Shop out there the biggest question
make sure you get out there look around
I'm gonna go check the fish out there
you go check oh they got fish there yeah
the biggest aquarium in like North
America I did not know that I didn't
either good that's a fancy so I'll
probably be sleeping there doing shows
at night Friday Saturday two shows only
Friday two shows Saturday Naples Florida
Fish in there February 16th through the
18th then Bakersfield I end February in
Bakersfield California one night only
it's almost sold out February 23rd go
get your tickets Bray eye change braz
March 3rd two shows on a Friday Saturday
I have to cancel I have a fight
companion for the Jon Jones fight so
Bray is now just one night only March
3rd that's a February two shows on
February I'm sorry March 3rd uh Friday
night only in Brea California get your
tickets uh t or fatkz.com or thick
boy.com well listen if you're in Canada
if you're in Edmonton you come to the
comic strip all right I'm there February
23 24 25 been a while three years maybe
four years since I've been in in Africa
has been locked down it's been it's been
locked down Nashville Tennessee Zanies
March two three and four New York New
York Sony Hall March 11th and I got West
Nyack uh New York Levity Live March 16
17 18. love it go see Brian Collins let
me ask you a question when you wake up
you obviously do your deep squats you do
your meditation you read the vedanta but
do you check your credit score can I
check my fish first okay because then I
go I check my fish and I go I want my
credit scores I wish there was something
I could do about it yeah well there is
because you don't have to check it
because chime the company chime will
check it for you they have a secure
chime credit Builder Visa credit card
you can start building credit with your
own money it reports your payments to
credit bureaus to help you build credit
over time their members see an increase
of 30 points on average now check this
out hold up another crazy annual no
annual fees okay what about large
security
let's check my credit though no credit
check oh my God start your journey today
with John credit Journey sign up takes
only two minutes and doesn't affect your
credit score like Brian said get started
at chime.com fighter that's chime.com
the chime credit Builder Visa credit
card is issued by stride bank and a
pursuant of a license with Visa USA
chime checking account 200 qualifying
direct deposit required to apply for the
secured chime credit Builder Visa credit
card regular on-time payment history can
have a positive impact on your credit
score impacts to score May Vary and some
user scores may not improve out of
network ATM withdrawal fees May apply
accepted money pass ATMs in a 7-Eleven
or any all point or VISA plus Alliance
ATM how did you get that yeah chime.com
fighter let me ask you something you're
an NBA fan oh dude I'm the biggest fan
you see LeBron cry the other night
because he got fouled against this uh
Celtics didn't see him cry oh my god
well NBA fans it's time to bring Hoops
action to the palm of your hand with
DraftKings Sportsbook an official Sports
button partner of the NBA this week new
customers can bet five dollars and win
two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly instantly Plus for a limited
time all new and existing customers can
get a no sweat same game parlay every
day go to the DraftKings Sportsbook app
right now opt-in and place the same game
parlay on any NBA game and if it doesn't
hit you'll get a free BET back Daddy all
right bet on my nuggets best team in the
league Ben Lakers LeBron's gonna come
back parlay that you win Bank easy
download the app right now sign up with
the code fighter new customers can bet
five dollars on the NBA and get 200 in
free bets instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook an official Sports button
partner of the NBA with code fighter
minimum age eligibility restrictions
apply void in Ohio see show notes for
details DraftKings promo code fighter
why the [__] do you wake up so early
because it's simply Mark Wahlberg that's
just so I can get annoying
horrendous it noises
sometimes but sometimes I didn't even go
to sleep but the whole point was is that
I never adjusted the wake-up time that
was the point so that cuts you it cuts
you six months from now in Adderall
rehab now you just like literally
self-inflicted adversity is what's
needed to match a rising success I'm
sure when someone asks you to go out
you're like well
even dinner or whatever when I say go
out like do some oh yeah six six pm
that's what I'm saying but if they're
like it's at eight you're like well it's
gonna cut into my you know rest I would
still do it because I like then I would
say well hey if I'm tired in the morning
I'll be operating from like a different
stage of Consciousness and then I'll tap
me into a different level of creativity
when I make my content that I give to
the world every day so I always look at
it as a positive one of my uh clients
he's one of the most famous people in
the world his dad was a musician that
everybody knows and um the other day he
didn't sleep and he got on the call and
I was like are you on [__] are you
micro dosing for are you on LSD right
now are you high and he's like he's like
no man like no and I'm like yeah you
[__] are who cares but we went into a
real deep session about some stuff and
it was one of the best ones ever because
you step into something like really out
of deficit and you're not trying to
perform as hard and then when you do it
makes you more proud and I mean it just
kind of took the pressure off and we had
a great session but the thing is is um I
just like to make my life difficult to
match you have to if you're Rising
success has to be matched by with
discipline yeah or you're gonna
do what everyone else does comfort seek
that Comfort seeking is going to lead to
a massive massive decline in your life I
mean everybody that's kind of like the
value of any controversy if you can
survive 10 years and [__] level 4
State pen in California which is all
gang [__] and you gotta walk that
Razor's Edge bro I mean it's it must
feel like everything else is easy after
that see I had to do everything the best
in there and that's what we do in there
is we program so you're known in there
and validated by your program like they
value You by how you conduct yourself
each day if Brian's a [__] dope fiend
like that dude's a wrecked dope fiend
next thing that happens he's in that
he's on the next thing smoking like he's
gonna go have to stab the next dude or
fight the next dude or something because
he's alive yeah so you're Expendable
you're not a solid asset who would you
want around me when a riot kicks off
don't feed Brian or big ass [__] uh
shove that's [__] been hitting the
weights he's crazy you don't [__] around
he's on point his boots are on I mean
he's ready to go guys I just need it
[__] are like that yeah
these dudes are muscle and dope careful
[__] will be in the day room
with a sweater on like this with a rig
right there and like the cops walking by
I'm like God damn [__] you just
you just got your rig right there full
of dope damn they walk by and just be
like what like I was in the shoe and uh
they were fishing dope so the shoe is
already housing here special houses yeah
yeah
he's got a little piece
hey can you hold our pocket during this
podcast that's the best no no Wes tells
me I just take this finger and I Loop it
through your belt loop and I just follow
you really closely around that's what
you're gonna do when we leave here yeah
I want to hear about all this but yeah
but literally we're in a shoe and I just
I roll back I was I was in the bmu I
caught a A1 so an A1 is like the highest
it's attempted murder murder and um uh
serious bodily injury with an inmate
manufactured weapon so I got an inmate
manufacturer weapons I show you so I cut
his [__] whole [__] face off and
then uh they put me in the bmu and I'm
like [__] dude my life's [__] over
they bring him back to the housing unit
I'm like oh this [__] itch you know and
I'm just like I'm [__] and the captain
comes by he's like I'm like hey when are
they moving me back to the block he's
like you're [__] like you already had
four strikes they're only riding on two
because that case they can only really
pin two on me but in my case it was
robbery in the first
um burglary in the first
um assault gbi with a deadly weapon and
then um an accomplished present in a
like if it's a housing it makes it like
a um uh what's it called a home invasion
this is all this is all my charges on
the streets
so I lost at trial and got uh yeah I got
the four strikes and so they just
piggyback them and then I end up doing
the time on the two but um so then I'm
in prison and I get this uh A1 case to
get that away I hate to interrupted but
get that A1 we shank the guy and gave
him the black Dolly a smile why did you
cut his face we were talking [__] about
dips we're in the day room about this
yeah he was saying that my God my hips
weren't low enough oh damn I'm like dog
shut [__] up like he was like a halfway
slow dude from NorCal and I'm like hey
shut the [__] up you slow ass
[__] you said you weren't going
blow parallel yeah in the second
argument the second someone
um the second someone uh disrespects you
in public you're done like you can't let
oh he did he did in front of people yeah
I disrespect him in public so he there
and then everyone all the other people
who run the block like I had the keys
but everyone else was like oh Sam you
got to do something about that so he
starts walking back to his cell and we
know what time it is and I'm just like
boom like I just already have my [__]
and they're like God damn Wes you're a
[__] psycho I go in there and we
start getting them up and I handled it
but um the whole thing is the cops came
in spraying Us in the cell and
everything I just knew my life I thought
I was committed and I'm done but um then
they take me to bmu the captain captain
Weir comes down and you had to do that
because you just had to do it because
like Everyone's Watching and you can't
be disrespected you have to do it at
that level because I could have just
fought him but I was just like so [__]
up by the time I'm like [__] this so you
you were kind of like [__] it I'm gonna
go away yeah I always wanted you did
some shitty things you were bad guys I
was horrible I went I didn't go to
prison for 10 years for missing a Boy
Scout meeting yeah
like literally I don't know how the guy
lived like I still say I wasn't me till
this day where the [__] yeah but they
they convicted me at trial the
[__] went a PF Changs came back
in 10 minutes dude this is how crazy it
was the the victim told 16 different
versions of the same story to police and
the first one was I was in Mexico this
happened it finally came down to my
lawyer going up there and saying make
him walk through every version of the
story and at the end of each version he
had to say that was a lie and then
finally come to the 16th version and he
goes ladies and gentlemen the jury we're
so we're supposed to convict Mr Watson
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt with this
story this 16th version that's not a
reasonable doubt they went to have pH
change came back and we're just [__]
boom like guilty they ain't gonna [__]
yeah like and I'm like Shackled to the
floor it looks like I'm free but I have
like uh weight ankle shackles and I'm
Shackled to the ground did you think you
were gonna get away though I they didn't
have a case really they had nothing like
it was just a victim talking [__] but I
guess that's enough now so the dips
thing was in prison though oh yeah but
the dip thing wasn't prison difference
but this was how I this is how I ended
up in prison but uh the dip thing was in
prison Captain Weir comes down he goes
um no you're [__] like you're getting
the da is going to pick this up did you
see the pictures and he shows me the
pictures and I'm like [__] I'm [__]
and then they bring me back to the shoe
and this goes to the heroin story so I
bring them back to the shoe and there's
like this Asian kid in the cell I'm like
what the [__] these [__] are
setting me up like they're trying to put
me in a cell with another race and you
can't deny a cell move like you have to
just go in there and [__] mash the
[__] like and the cops will do
that they know that a white dude can't
deny a cell so if they're trying to put
me in with a black or a Mexican or
Nation or something I just got to take
that cell move and go in a [__]
Mercury Siamese fish dude you gotta
start fighting just beat the life I got
I gotta make an example I'm in the fish
it's like flowerhorn fish all right put
two flour in the same tank they gotta
fight they fight yeah they gotta fight
and I'm betting on this one and this is
why you should own fish because you can
you can it's understand the life lesson
my fish tank my fish tank is gangly so
I'm a [__] they also refuse is that
what you call them uh flower flower head
I'm a flowerhorn flower horn yeah I
don't literally have like five million
in koi fish in a lake outside say one
and they're like this [__] big oh
[__]
one oh my [__] koi got killed by a
rabbit Balboa Park on my property with
[__] koi fish they're like this
[__] big so wait so so so so they put
you in with the nation put me in the
Asian he knows Kung Fu he's got his
[__] shoes off in the cell which is
like a number one rule you're not doing
and I look around I sign over to little
Chris I'm like
I'm like that's how I just said little
Chris so I signed up a little Chris I'm
like what what the [__] what is this
he's like nah he's good you know and I
go in and it says Asian cat swally Dylan
sulit swali he was uh he was an Asian
white boy but he was fully German but he
runs white and I go and I'm like what
the [__] dude and he he has a joint
rolled and he's like you wanna you smoke
I'm like oh [__] oh it's nice and then
yeah so we smoke a joint and but he's
black and white he looks Asian fully but
he runs white and then um the cop comes
back Sergeant Slaughter that's [__]
crazy as really his [__] name and
then the [__] comes back and I'm
I'm like stoned as [__] he's coming
to drop off my property and I have been
selling a lot of dope when I was online
so they come back to my cell and they're
dropping off bags of beans [__] soups
all coffee all this [__] in the shoe
nobody has that [__] because you can
only go to store uh you get a package uh
why are you doing that for you oh
because I just got my property because I
just hit the line so they got to bring
my property the one time you're gonna
get your [__] and he's dumping all my
[__] off and I'm like hey and he'd been
and seeing me in the bmu stressing I
just smoked that joint and he looks in
he's like you look different I said shut
the [__] up and hand me my [__] fool
he's like it smells and I [__] shut
up and having my [__] Doug and we just
start making tamales and [__] we're
chilling but like next morning these
dudes are fishing dope they're fishing
heroin like that means that you like
slide a car from one cell to the other
and the dude slides his card out like
that like remote right there and they
hook each other and they pull a line to
where they and they tie some on the end
so they had like uh heroin and a rig
tight on the end and he pulls it and the
cop he pulls it all hard the cops
running after it he's like he's pulling
I'm like oh [__] pull that [__] and he
pulls it and it just slaps against the
wall and the cop grabs it now the cop
looks in it he's like and my dude's all
[__] gouled out and he's rubbing his
face he's all hey man give me my mail
and the cops like [__] you dude look at
this [__] and they throw us all in the
shower for four [__] days and they're
just like you guys somebody better tell
on someone what's the shower just the
showers the showers lock in the shoe oh
yeah yeah yeah but they just they lock
you in the showers because you have to
be escorted everywhere okay so they
throw us in the showers for like four
days in our boxers and they're like just
we're just like [__] they're trying to
get someone a snitch nobody says
anything but they said it so they sent
us back to ourselves but the thing is is
like they're just constantly [__]
with you and it's all this one big drug
game and [__] to where
right after that get on the phone I call
someone on GP in the line and there one
guy works in the the diet section of the
the scullery the kitchen and the guy
works the kosher trays and I'm like okay
put some more [__] on this tray you know
and like I'm calling from a phone in the
back and he's putting [__] on this tray
and this tray is a kosher meal that only
a black dude could get because and the
cops can't dig through it they'll dig
through every other meal to see what's
in the food they can't dig through the
kosher tray because it's religious and
then it comes back to the black dude the
Muslim guy I call the muslim dude they
fish it over and we're already loked out
again and I have the whole back cracking
and like this is like in the shoe like
the the most secure party you're
hustling oh just everywhere everywhere
it doesn't even matter it's like the
Mark Zuckerberg
but that that's the thing is if you go
to my Ig right now go to Watson
underscore fit scroll down I had phones
the whole time I posted every day and it
was black and white photos like I'm I'm
doing lunges with a kid in the day room
right there that's [__] crazy that's
that's in prison I'm I got my phone
right there filming and I'm posting on
Instagram now that kid uh he just
volunteered that or you were like I was
like get the [__] over here I'm curious
too with the kid he was just like yeah
you can lift me that kid was worth he he
was doing like eight years they were all
like at that point I had the keys at
that place that was when I dropped
points and I was at a level two so then
like all these [__] I had been
on a four I had been down almost 10
years at that point and these guys were
doing shorter terms but um I posted on
my Instagram in prison from 2014 to
December 17 2017 the day I got out
there's me sitting on my rack right
there people are always like where's the
cell pics I'm like we didn't have
smartphones on the level fours when I
first fell once I got to threes and twos
then we started to have smartphones I
fell when there was [__] flip phones
what was going on in your head right
there do you remember I was like
literally just said I'm gonna take over
the world when I get up how to make
money that's what you were thinking yeah
when I get when I get out my phone you
made money in [__] prison I would
imagine I made money in prison illegally
and legally and you can't sell torment I
can't Stout are you [__] me I gotta
I gotta [__] I gotta hire you but
then like honestly I just started
realizing how to monetize social media
and um I found an app that I could use
to try to do what was most valuable to
me which was help someone track their
macros which is losing fat help someone
do their workouts which is raising their
frequency and feeling better have
someone get on a zoom call with me so I
can really get in their mind and get
them to structure their core beliefs so
we'll have them drop their negative
vices their drinking their alcohol their
drugs how do you do that's interesting
right so everybody seems to have this
sort of self-saboteur or oh dude right
it's a subconscious mind right look if
if you if the subconscious mind is
secretly notifying like you you're the
subconscious mind is secretly taking
account of how you treat yourself so if
you're not aligned consciously there's
no alignment with your conscience and
you're not living you're living
incongruently then your subconscious
mind knows that which means you got to
tell the truth if you're not true to
yourself then your subconscious mind
will make you sabotage so the whole
thing is you have to live congruently
because you're ashamed of yourself or
you're just like you know you don't
value yourself you don't value so if you
don't value yourself and you're like no
I'm going to do this diet then at the
end of the day you're going to be in the
cupboard it's all crazy because you
don't stop here and I keep thinking
about the Jordan Peterson said something
he goes in my 35 years of being a
clinical psychologist I've never seen
anyone ever get away with anything even
once exactly you can twist the fabric up
you can twist the fabric reality for a
while but when people are their whole
life is [__] up you can trace it back
to that [__] decision you made over
there yes
that [__] is in my in my 56 years I
believe that's very real no 100 that's
why I just got rid of everything people
ask me Wes what do you do or I'll pull
up one of my stupid cars or I'll be
living a certain way what do you do what
do you do I say it's what I don't do
because everyone's really doing enough
but it's the stuff that they shouldn't
be doing that they're still doing that's
keeping them from moving forward at the
pace so you won't even have a drink I've
never no last to my drink was in prison
I had some I had some Bruno I'd love to
try something dude they're so good
though like they did out of oranges in
my maple syrup Brendan has a problem
dude it's like it was fire like they
were watching a football game and I sip
a little bit of that maple syrup and
oranges made [__] uh Bruno I'm like
oh that shit's [__] good bro where's
your business plan on this we could have
bottled this dude literally I could
never sell so I called Hooch I'll call
it so [__] bad yeah Credit Karma it
is [__] like friend stop take your
business cap off
so stupid dude it's [__] can you
believe that hey the second I drank in
prison for the first time in a long time
I had some speed and I just did a bump
now I [__] yeah I didn't then I had
by that time I had mango from maravillas
this essay from southsider and this full
little man uh from uh kalimas and
they're they're making me whine at both
ends of the [__] prison and I I've
got batches going over here and now I go
on like a two-week Bender but [__]
smoking speed [__] with Chucky and
Capone Capone from LMP Chucky from La
awesome and now I'm off to charge the
line smoking [__] speed I'm on a
phone on Plenty of Fish looking out here
I'm trying to talk to chicks partying
again you're an extreme rock hard in
prison hammered on speed stay up all
night like [__] just looking at like
straight porn videos like yeah xxnx big
butt videos
but that sounds like you're an extremist
yeah I'm just like I'm not even like
jacking off I got one hand on my dick
and I'm like looking at porn like porn
porn porn porn and like and then like
the morning comes it's time to go to
Chow I'm like [__] like when the
cops walk I like I put my phone away I
like get under the covers and I can wait
for the dude to walk and I'm thinking
like this [__] [__] at the end
of my bed this piece of [__] he's still
[__] sitting there I'm going crazy on
speed you know and I rip my blanket I'm
like [__] get away from my
nobody's there I just totally make it up
my ass Jesus going crazy my [__] for
like two weeks I lost my [__] on uh on a
speed and [__] alcohol bender and
that was when I quit that's when I quit
all drugs so now here's my question I'm
going to jail Brian count
just a regular guy I'm a regular wood I
think they call him you're a wood you're
a ruby wood where are you from
New York grew up over here where are you
from here Venice California yeah you
could just be like what is that like San
Fernando or San Gabriel
yeah
west side yeah what would the L.A do for
that
Crips or something or why did you do rap
Venice like it's a hood right it's 13
and Shoreline Crips yeah there's two
things you're not in that but I'm not in
those of it those would have been those
have been the essays in the blacks yeah
yeah I'm also a man in his 50s you know
you get a die Brian no no hold on I'll
keep you busy
hey I'll throw hands that's one thing
that doesn't happen so everybody yeah
and GP prison California there is no gay
[__] yeah that's right if there was any
gay [__] everyone would be [__] dead
in his mind he's like bummer oh I'm not
going damn it oh oh I'm not going I did
one again everyone would die no but in
the other prisons like the guys are
different states and [__] and PC they're
smoking speed and [__] each other
wait wait so I'm going I'm going to jail
Wes I'm going to jail give me some
advice what do I got to do
um
all you have to do is come in you'd come
with your paperwork you'd have your bed
roll your fish kit you'd roll up one of
my people would come get your paperwork
from you you probably know it's me
because I'm sitting there reading acting
like I ain't paying attention and they
come dump the paperwork off to my check
your [__] drop it down on My Bunkie he
gets on the phone checks Megan loss make
sure that you're not a [__] chomo if
you are you're [__] dead if you're
good you're good does he have no tattoos
on his face
and uh be up at a certain time shower
workout stay the [__] out there you're
not gonna do well I'm hanging
Redemption you're gonna have a little
bird in your pocket and you should be
the old guy I'm the bird man the old
bird man you're the stupid old guy now
let's I'm listening the West no there's
there's a lot of old dudes there with
the business scooter he was about your
age you look kind of like you he's with
the business and he just said he's like
I'm ready Wes whatever I'm like you get
your old ass broken off dude chill the
[__] out go to your goddamn also you're
16 named scooter yeah but that's all of
them are like 60 going on 16. and so
those guys those guys kind of get left
alone because they're just all yeah if
you're white you're protected by the
other white dude saying if someone [__]
a Brian I have to go I have to jump with
Brian don't matter so you know that I
have to jump with you and every white
dude has to jump with you there's no way
around it if another race [__] with you
then well now conversely if you get
jumped I gotta jump in too yeah 100 oh
yeah and if you don't you get you get
mashed right but the majority of prison
is has been uh Latin is the yeah that's
all it's all Southsiders it's basically
Southsiders Pisces Woods on one side of
the building blacks Asians and
Northerners on the other side of the
building Northern Arizona Northern
Mexicans and it's split in the middle
and like the Southsiders are like 80
percent of the block like the next are
like the blacks and then everybody else
has these South Side there's a run
they're the biggest army yeah there's
like 10 [__] Woods in every building
and there's like 45 Southsiders out of
like 260 of them out of 200. so Woods
have to watch their ass when we roll up
to South cider so like you do the whole
thing is like usually like we're all us
on this side will war against that side
of the day room it's like we're all on
this side we're together that side's
together but sometimes you kick it off
with this Outsiders if like a white boy
gets a drug debt or there's a problem
you can't pay like they'll [__] us up
it's stressful man hey do you do some of
your boys call you from back in the day
oh yeah okay man I get 100 right now uh
he's actually a Game the rapper of the
games Foster brother his name is Nathan
Belton but we call him whiskey he's from
sfv every time he gets out he's like oh
you go on my Instagram right now and
comments and he's like he's just all uh
he's just all um uh like I even wrote
the game on one of my things I said is
Nathan really your Foster brother and he
said you got my phone
look at this [__]
you gotta You Gotta Laugh and [__] like
this because you're in prison you're
like this white dude's telling me the
game is his foster brother and you're
like yeah [__] right shut up yeah he
doesn't look very yeah you shouldn't
really say it but like what's the news
he's trying to invest or something you
got did you hold on to friendships did
you make deep friendships or no no no
let's use your burnt yeah yeah burn burn
burn
I mean could if you put Wes in a movie
as a convict the director would be like
dude
him and Stevie blue eyes let me do a
buddy movie so this is the game
there's a message between us
and I go look it I go one question homie
is Nathan belt your Foster brother no
big deal curious was locked up with a
guy he says yep and I said in the pic
and he uh he sends back the arm but this
is the rap for the game so it really was
his [__] Foster brother wow but I
mean the thing is is fools in prison be
telling Whoppers you know maybe tell
somebody
yeah huge [__] Brian
I'm a black belt and everything
[__] Whoppers
um it's pretty wild though man I thought
yeah look at it that's crazy
yeah but that that's why only reason I
brought it up because he got out like
three days ago and he's all up in my
feed and I'm like I don't write you guys
back until you guys prove that you're
not a [__] problem out here right
yeah because of my life up yeah excuse
me as a guy who has to your personality
is the kind of guy who has to put very
strong boundaries or confines on
yourself because you can go to The Other
Extreme oh yeah we can't give you I
don't I don't trust a man without a dark
side yeah so like I need to see your
dark if you don't show me your like
what's your youngest shot over yeah like
[__] that like I I'd never trust
[__] on dark side but the man
who willingly controls that I can
respect that dude like I have every
[__] problem known to man who's who
do you want as a life coach [__] the
guy who lived the best life ever his
whole life or the guy who lived the
worst [__] life got out and turned
into the best life so Carl Jung said
this about the Great Cars he said he
said if you want if you're gonna you're
gonna be if you want to Be an Effective
psychologist and you really don't want
to understand human psyche if you don't
get in touch with your own dark side
right if you don't get in touch with the
fact that you can do the worst [__]
possible and enjoy it meaning everybody
has everything I used to get a sick
sensation off of making people [__]
just piss himself well so so that's but
that's human so that means we all have
that dark and that light side but your
roots have to touch healthier branches
to touch oh so good young was such a
[__] yes nut bro and he said that's
how you end the Civil War in your own
brain once you can come to terms a
little bit like saying if you can be if
you can understand violence be
comfortable in violence then then you
can you can hold it back and restrict it
the best thing that I learned from him
was uh
neurosis and I wrote the cop deleted the
cause of neurosis is pain avoidance pain
avoidance so everyone's avoiding pain so
much Neurosis Neurosis is mild mental
illness uh obsessive compulsive
disorders anxiety depression all these
things everyone in the world's suffering
from is Neurosis they're suffering from
Neurosis because we live so [__] soft
this world based on affluence where we
think we're struggling and it's the
pussiest life ever so that's why I live
such a life that's that's seemingly
difficult but that's what keeps me with
such a clear mind and that's what did it
in prison where we were talking in the
room before Seneca used to do that for
oh dude you got all the hits
Seneca would take a day or two a month
and he would sleep on the floor with
just a small blanket with just bread and
water it's nice to take a week just to
show himself that this is what people
are afraid of I can handle this that's
the best the stoics were the best [__]
Seneca read on the shortness of life you
will realize that that there are certain
truths about being a human being that
are 3000 years old that are as relevant
today as they ever were the books that I
I keep handy is uh Art of Living
Epictetus and then meditations Aurelius
thank you and I just keep those right
there all the time just to just stick
where where I need to be like desires
are [__] just nasty I I really um I
really live in like a flow state to
where I'm never truly Desiring anything
I'm working to attain what I would
desire but I never just sit in a stage
of desire which is a real low frequency
State I don't teach people like low
frequency yeah I don't teach people all
the [__] like everyone listen I go
high frequency or low frequency and then
I show them the frequency chart and I'm
like okay what causes us to us to be in
these high frequency emotions what
caused us to be in these low frequency
emotions [__] anything else that
happened in your life [__] your stupid
trauma [__] all this [__] [__] what
you think is guiding you you have this
Moment In This Moment are you going to
choose high frequency or low frequency
because I tell people you're freaking is
what you frequently see so we make sure
that you're just in a high frequency
state but everybody in the [__] world
is defining themselves in that low
frequency set of emotions they're like
oh this is me it's like no that's the
moment [__] and you're in
control of your moments with your
thoughts and actions so what's your
thoughts and actions you can actually
like mold any moment to fit you and if
you know where you fit on this chart and
you know the steps it takes to get you
into a love and grateful state from
anger like anger is almost a high
frequency emotion compared to shame and
guilt which everyone's operating from
because they're not holding their word
to themselves like I don't want to eat
that again then they eat all that [__]
and they're like oh I feel so shameful
or I don't want to do dope again and
they do I don't want to drink again they
do I don't want to cheat again they do
and they live in this shame and guilt
which is the bottom of that so how do
you how do you acceptance is a high
frequency a moment a high frequency
exceptions that you you are an addict of
something except since it just it
happened and like you're in control of
the moment so if you just accept that
you're in control moment and you don't
like label yourself and hold yourself to
these thoughts that keep you down there
and the thought changes now the thought
changes to like acceptance and then you
go into an act of self-love which is
self-investment a workout or something
then you'll automatically get into that
place but I mean the whole thing is I've
never seen someone be running a marathon
and be like Oh I'm so shameful for me
once you get into that crazy deep
workout you forget about everything and
you enter Flow State once you enter Flow
State you're at scratch again to be able
to choose what you want to think and
feel and that's why I use burpees in
prison like I'd be like oh my [__] is
probably [__] sewing right now this
stupid [__] like I just be in my head
like oh [__] I had Sancho answer the
phone one time I called he's like Wes
you've been gone for eight years this
ain't your chick anymore I'm like oh
[__] you I'm gonna kill you when I get
out yeah and like she wasn't dude it was
on and off I was [__] holding on to a
dream of course but um but then you know
I could always overtake anything with a
really intense workout that just put me
into Flow State flow state was hitting
scratch and and then I could just have
that book right there meditations or a
quote book or something positive and I
would insert that just that gem that
that core belief that well just what you
just said about Neurosis man oh dude
that's [__] great because people
understood that 100 one thing from Young
and he taught that what 45 years ago
yeah man [__] Pete doing what's
difficult is is something you can
freedom from self and these horrible
moments that we're [__] creating
though
your perception did you have followers
in prison did you start I like ten
thousand followers in prison no I'm
saying guys storm the capital where guys
in oh yeah no do not if you go to my
page that has the transformations in
prison so I had people doing
transformations in prison so you're
already doing this [__] yeah I was like
already like doing their macros and
their workouts like as one one of the
dudes Smiley from OCS uh who do you look
up to who are your Heroes I mean I work
with people I don't think anyone should
really have Heroes but I mean I I
there's people I will listen to there's
about this that's not in prisoners
there's people you respect there's
people I respect enough to listen to and
they have to hold like a certain set of
uh like standards you know yeah and I
mean there's like very few people how
did you and uh Chet Hanks make he speaks
the world oh Chet's my boy Chad um he
got him he got on my mid-level program
when he was still uh drinking and
getting partying too much and then um
then we got him sober once you got him
sober started teaching him uh more of
like the stock philosophy he's like he's
saying like living harder to really like
engage your life and love the moments
more we all had it so [__] easy that
affluenza played its course on us [__]
us over and um didn't they do this thing
about the some of the richest kids in
the world the the children of the
richest people in the world's not likely
to commit suicide 400 more likely to
commit suicide like human beings no
passion yeah we need structure we need
struggle we need all that I mean the
whole thing is is you think you want it
easy but those difficulties that you
face are the ones that actually will
make you who you really want to be so I
get to walk around with like [__]
trophy on my back that I went through 10
years of prison and now look how the
[__] my life is like I I went through
[__] hell to come out and exist how I
how I get to live and it means the world
to me like that I went through all that
people don't have those measuring sticks
like everything you went through is
going to mean more than what you
attained out here you know and then
everyone you're able to help from that
because I truly feel this is our purpose
is to heal ourselves and teach others to
do the same and like just even the words
we've dropped right here like if people
are [__] aware enough they'll be able
to say
they're right whenever I feel like I
have anxiety I'm gonna go [__] just
I'm just gonna go running you know even
if we could go Forest gumbo but you just
go run it if a [__] just ran out
the [__] door when they were straight
anxious start doing squats just do air
squats that's what breka says Gary
Brecker he says when he's on a plane
flight he calls it snacking on exercise
I call it like a 60 40 20 workflow where
I do the same thing but he said he's on
a long flight he goes in the [__]
lavatory and he does uh air squats and
breathes heavy he talks about the blood
out blood oxidation level of happiness
and anger and all this [__] I don't get
in all that I'm just like I'm free for
myself again for a moment what about
meditation and prayer they'd be let's
yeah let's let's take a break can we
take a break because here's the thing
you can you're in the how often are you
in your car dude all the time bro there
are over 5 million car crashes like in
2020 over 5 million car crashes more
than 15 000 a day six hundred dollars an
hour dude are you talking about a lawyer
right now because listen I've had a
family member slip out of restaurant yep
and she had to have the help of a lawyer
and she only she only had to pay if she
won and that's what happened dude okay
so listen you you got you got crazy
amounts of accidents on the road well
you you when you sue somebody you're
suing their insurance company and a lot
of times you have to do that to make
yourself whole so if you're injured in a
car accident what happened did Insurance
handle it did the insured party get a
lot of questions yep did you think that
did you they think or of or have to sue
those are all the questions that run
through your brain okay I've been in
accidents myself and the first thing I
say to myself is at least I got
insurance to take care of yes but here
are a couple things you can sue when
you're in an accident to be made whole
did you know that you're not suing the
person once again you hit rather uh or
who hit you right now but do I need a
ton of money
okay now here's what's great yeah please
you basically Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury Law Firm they
have over a hundred offices Nationwide
more than 800 lawyers they've gotten
over 15 billion dollars recovered for
clients and Morgan Morgan has a proven
track record of fighting to get you full
and fair compensation in but here's the
great thing submitting an injury claim
of Morgan Morgan is so easy it's more
like using an app than hiring a lawyer
in fact in fact you're basically in
about six steps or less you filed
yourself
this is crazy and usually their fee is
free unless unless they win yeah if they
win you get paid they get paid if you're
ever injured in an accident you can
check out Morgan and Morgan their fee is
free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com
fighter or dial pound law that's
pound529 from your cell phone that's f o
r the people.com fighter or pound law
pound 529 from your cell
I I really don't meditate I live in a
meditative State like my whole life is
meditating when you said but when you
said you wake up at 2 45 and then you
visualize I do like a visualization
yeah it's the same thing conversion yeah
but I don't I don't like all like that
other [__] like I think that [__] yeah I
think it's I think like like too much of
that [__] is like it's like mental
masturbation it's like [__] it's
spiritual bypassing all those [__]
people who say they meditate and
visualization practices and [__] I'm
like did you visualize yourself being
that [__] fat and that big of a broke
loser [__] what the [__] is all
that doing for you if you still [__]
look like that what the [__] go out and
do it like how are you not exactly like
I just want like it's real quick like
during my morning as I'm getting ready
I'm visual I actually do it deductively
so I wake up and anything I regret from
the day before is what I'm focusing on
not doing today I don't like visualize
this [__] La La Land in perfect
[__] scenario yeah because that's how
you have that's how you live a life of
pain your expectations don't meet
reality well now you're [__] but I
mean the whole thing is is like I really
just wake up in the morning I'm a true
coach I want Solutions I don't want
[__] platitudes so I'm like okay what
do I regret from yesterday I regret this
it's not [__] happening today and so
my whole thing is just snapping on
people like I just get real angry and
real short of people because I'm just
smart and so like I can't deal with slow
ass [__] I'm like spit it out stupid
speed the [__] up you know God damn but
um like I just can't be slow and [__]
and then I you know it teaches me to
measure backwards remember when I was
like people so that's the only way that
I can get free from that like not having
that energy leak of the whole world like
one of your regrets will be like what
like what if I should have to eat
chocolate not just like uh like maybe
like something in a relationship like
calling my chick out on something I
could have just like because I usually
just go like this am I in or out like I
keep it simple am I in this relationship
where I'm out right and like if I'm in
it shut the [__] up about anything else
and if I'm out then get the [__] out are
you married no no kids I was I was
married for like three or four years it
didn't work out we got another we had a
lot of [__] when you got out of
prison yeah yeah and I had like a
stepson
it was cool though I still got massive
love for both of them like they're
they're [__] awesome but I'm in a new
relationship no kids no no do you want
kids I would love that would be my only
dream that's why I tell people who come
into my program a lot of people come to
my program and I teach them how to
monetize like their passion online so if
you have like a zone of Genius say like
a real estate guy then I I attach like
your real estate background to like um
life and wisdom and I make you a course
that you can sell for a lot of money and
then like someone else who's a fitness
guy your Fitness background then like
your life and wisdom I make you a course
so you can sell for a lot of money and
like you teach it and you run it it's
[__] amazing because it's your hobby
it's your passion it's your zone of
Genius it's you being like transcending
self and giving back to the world what
fulfilled you and brought you to that uh
state of self-actualization so once
people come actualize they have to
transcend and that's what I bring these
people to when they get like that flat
line where they don't have an outlet so
I teach them to have an outlet but
they'll come to me and they'll just want
my money and I'm like you don't [__]
get it [__] and they're like like
what I'm like I want what you have
I want your family and the life you have
and I have this money I'm like the only
way for you to get my money is for you
to show me how to get what you have a
lot of guys like me have a lot of money
and their families are [__] up and
their their lives are [__] up and they
chase money too much or whatever which I
don't think is possible but there a lot
of people [__] that up because they're
too extreme on one end or the other I
don't really care either way I feel like
I'm a father to the world so I if I have
kids or no I'm not but you're right
about that you see you see people who
chase this
idea of success and it's like there's a
saying Hollywood you know you climb a
lot of people are climbing to the top of
this wall they get to the top and they
realize it's the wrong wall or they
don't like the view you know happiness
you see that [__] that's that's the
thing is I'll tell like my fitness
people or my other people who are giving
people life coaching and um I'm like you
got to sell those richer people what you
have because they want what you have yes
yeah they have money you want our money
yes and we'll give you our money teach
us how to get that yes because we're not
struggling here [__] yeah and
they're they're trying to like
they're just doing it wrong because they
they're one side they're they're one
side they don't have Insight they well
my experience is that I've seen very
successful people whether they're
billionaires whatever and what what
actually is motivating them is the the
initial motivation has never been a
healthy place it's a hole they're always
trying oh it's a nasty place you know
the the three hyper success traits that
make millionaires no okay there's the
first one is you you're better than
everyone hey what the [__]
wood these are in prison these are the
three hyper success trades hold on
where's my camera
look at the billionaire list yeah yeah
but I don't know where I'm sorry number
number one number one is um you think
you're better than everyone okay number
two is
um you're never satisfied to a point of
insecurity which that's what you're
going on and number three is impulse
control those are what make a hyper
successful individual and I mean the
thing is is those first two they suit
you but they alienate you like a
[__] so so like you're destined
to be alone if you're going to be at the
top but that's okay because I mean one
of the most famous people on the planet
the other day called me and I'm like hey
is everything okay Doug and he's like
yeah yeah I was just checking on you I
said why he said nobody checks on us and
I'm like oh so I'm on your level hell
yeah they think he's good yeah because
they assume he's good he assumes he's
good but um and that's what these other
Elon was that's what these other people
don't realize they can provide people
who have money that are like trying to
help people and Coach people is that
like uh everything that they have and
that's what I tell them I'm like you
have what I want I have what you want so
yeah let's [__] let me show you how
to get it but so those billionaires have
problems
yeah that's that's why you have to
self-inflict adversity to match your
Rising success level if you don't if
your discipline doesn't match your
success you're [__] I mean look at
Bill Gates body recently Jesus Jesus
those dude how can you act like you're
happy with yourself when you look like
that like it's just the biggest lie like
when you have to lie to yourself
consistently do you know how not present
you are yeah like if you don't that's a
huge part you have to earn presence
people don't realize to be fully present
in life you have to be proud of your
presence if you're not proud of your
presence you'll never own the moment
that's why you see someone who's like
fat as [__] walking into a restaurant
picking their shirt out their tits it's
like [__] you're not even here
right now you're you're like looking at
me through you're looking at yourself
through his eyes his eyes and her eyes
and like you're just fully just
critiquing yourself so massively when I
did the work and I'm walking in going
these [__] want to see me and
I'm loving it some people are delusional
human beings that when you take struggle
away they will invent a way to struggle
like you know self-sabotage yeah that's
what that Joe always said that yeah I
was at dinner with um a bunch of people
my buddy made a lot of money and his
friends were awesome I know and his
friends were all super best way to be
every friend will say but they're all
they were all rich as [__] and every one
of them was they were but so all of them
were talking about well I'm beating them
to it no because they are
so I met this dinner with these guys
maybe and every one of them no these
guys were all like oh Elton had to tell
me how their house was featured in
architectural digest uh mine was
actually on some crazy Sotheby's listing
but what was interesting is that they
were all in their 50s 60s and they still
just fell competing they were still
competing and here was what was
interesting about him almost to a man
they were all [__] really really
overweight which was surprising and I
thought to myself something's going on
with you you don't you dislike yourself
that much where you're you're you're
feeding an addiction that you still
haven't overcome like you reached you
reached nirvana you thought you were and
now you just can't stop it or they're
just lazy
it's an emotional thing yeah just
filling a void but I mean the thing is
is once you learn to control those
disciplines you have to link them to
something else so like there was
something else I wanted in my life it
would make me control my eating better
and usually with me it was like I could
control my negative reaction to people
if I control the eating and I had to
couple that in my mind like if I go
cheat on my diet those that don't
reflect they project and so if I cheat
on my diet I'll feel like [__] and I'll
project feeling like [__] onto people
and it'll be the people around me that's
what people don't get like so they have
to connect that to like those they love
and their view of life and their how
much they enjoy life so that they don't
cheat on their diet because cheating on
their diet causes it a negative inward
view of self to negative inward view of
self has been projected on other people
when you're truly winning a life you
don't have like the problems like even
if like say my girl wants to argue or
something I said babe baby stop stop I'm
winning
and she's like what I'm like I'm [__]
winning I don't argue with people that's
what losers do you you can go ahead and
take that [__] and figure it out
yourself yeah and does that work yeah no
she gets pissed but I just let her be
pissed oh that's how you feel it so you
say to her yeah yeah I said that [__] to
my wife I'm like okay I said she says
I'm like I'm winning if I went I'm
winning I'm winning I'm winning my wife
would take I have a cast iron pan she
would strike up to your face oh my
chicks are real like smart and she goes
I guess she's like you trigger me more
than anyone in the world thank you
because she wants to grow and I'd say
see winning winning all right
you'll be like suck on these two pieces
like I'm fully committed to my chick
fully I do everything and then I I don't
have any I don't cheat I don't do
anything like that but my whole thing is
I won't call her she's like you won't
call me I'm like I'll never call you and
she's like that's [__] what I'm like
you have to call me
and I'm like and I'll answer right even
if I was in the middle of this [__]
podcast I'll answer if she calls and the
thing is is like I had too many chick
sounds controlling or I called too much
or I'm bugging them to where I'm like
I'm not [__] calling you you called
me whenever and I'll answer and I'll
always be loving and opening you're
trying to work on that yeah yeah and and
I I just I'm not gonna [__] do it and
if you don't want to be in a
relationship anymore don't call me
you'll never hear from me again and I'm
just like taking the upper hand
massively I'm like if you don't call me
he's an extremist you'll never hear me
yeah it has to be black people because
you were straight up stock yeah and now
you're just straight like yeah hey like
there's no in between All or Nothing
there's a million messages you're like
oh [__] I did write all that crazy [__]
no nothing yeah
you you're probably clinically manic oh
dude it's um it's basically what's
called euphoric Mania yes like it's it's
clinically diagnosed but you've made it
work for yourself yeah but that's that's
right what is that that's where it's
actually like a state of bliss so much
to where you're like like it would be
diagnosed as something else I lit I
literally like look at it as like almost
Enlightenment but
euphoric Mania wow inflated self-esteem
thinking you're Invincible more
talkative than usual talking so fast
others can't interrupt
dude happy or excited shoot me a picture
of you like um euphoric Mania I'm
winning I'm winning I'm winning [__]
don't call yeah well
the problem with that is the risk that
you you run there's not surrounding
yourself with people who say Hey [__]
face you're [__] up here or hey dude
you're wrong or hey dude there's a
different way to look at this you got to
be careful that your personality is not
so overwhelming that you end up being a
time I have a couple of times I have a
couple of top people I have calls with
weekly that are we do that too oh you do
yeah I got some homes billionaire top
people yeah like nah you gotta do this
thing but they're as bad as me in some
areas so it's mutual yes yeah well we do
the exchange of like yeah you're [__]
they hit me up like hey I'm about to do
this now you ain't doing that I'll
handle them up but I got they're like
hey you know when you're like you're so
mad like sometimes you like think about
getting out the car fighting the dude
he's like what about those weeks when
you just don't even realize you're
already out the [__] car yeah like oh
yeah yeah those are bad ones bro dial
back so do you chill out you on vacation
and stuff no no no no no yeah I'm like
in this massive grind State bro like I
just I well that's what that's how long
to probably right that's where oh yeah
dude prison's [__] intense all the
time you know you just knowing five
workouts a day [__] just trying to
stay uh keep your mind positive and
everything I mean it works well to help
people when you do more than them so
like you're asking them to do x amount
as a coach then they see that you do way
more than them and so it gives them no
excuse I I really only do all that [__]
for other people I don't really enjoy
life I'm a voyeur like I don't really
enjoy life it seems like you do I watch
life I don't really enjoy it per se like
I just got sad yeah I I view it so I
mean you don't enjoy life not really I
don't really I think enjoyment would be
like hey we're winning yeah but we're
winning but I think it's like man you
guys are winning and John and Jarman
would be a problem like I just I
basically
I basically don't trust it no I have a
[__] uh agenda so I have a mission
yeah I have a purpose where my purpose
is to is to literally create the man
that I admired in all ways okay and give
that man to the world at the highest
level that's good so that's what I'm
doing all the time but you enjoy that
you don't hate it I'm adverse to it
there's no reason to enjoy or just or
not enjoy it I'm you're agnostic yeah
exactly I have no feeling about it I'm
stoic towards it like I'm not if I
actually felt so elated by buying a new
Phantom Cash or something then I'd
probably be at the club looking like I
was cool but you buy nice cars so what's
that about yeah but I mean the whole
thing is those are like tax write-offs
and [__] like that and like anyways so
if I get rid of some [__] money when
you have no expenses right but I mean
also I like cars also nice and I like to
grow up like encouraging yeah I've
always liked cars on my phone you know
the ghetto drug dealer in me is like oh
we have to pull up yeah but uh
everything's a view like I have to like
everything has to be like visually
aesthetic to me but
um it's such an energy leak to design
entire stuff and not get it so like my
boy right here he's been wanting to buy
a Rolex for so damn long and a Lambo for
so long that he's probably bought the
Rolex and Lambo a hundred times over by
Googling prices about him and looking
for him so like essentially if you have
a desire go grab it get it and throw it
the [__] over there and get back to work
yeah so like I just if I desire
something I get it I attain it I don't
give a [__] about it I normalize it so
quick it's already there and then I go
back to more but gold but goals are good
like if his goal is a Ferrari or Lambo
no it's good but you have to like it was
kind of [__] boy once you can get it get
it because if not you're going to spend
two hours a day [__] daydreaming
about it and you're waiting you don't be
obsessed with that but it's good to have
a goal so yeah
do you teach people about goals though
or how do you yeah I mean the goal is to
create the man who can get anything so
you don't want to like have this
unrealistic goal like that you could
never meet you have to create the
individual who can do anything I'm
supposed to goals I want this I want
that you create I want
and then I'm like here's your habits in
Blueprint that'll get what you want
besides physical what are what are the
other habits I mean just even about
financial [__] like getting into an area
that has no cap financially and doing
the steps I tell them to do to build
their personal brand to then bring in
[__] shitloads of money to buy what
they want I mean so I can I can build
anyone a personal brand online with
online you're doing it with yeah just
off to social media even if they didn't
have a lot of followers I have guys who
paid me like 7 500 bucks and we're
making a million dollars a year two
million dollars I literally within when
they still had less than 15 000
followers and what are they doing
exactly they're selling like a training
Nutrition a mindset program and they'll
usually be on that program with me for a
while until they learn it they excel at
it so it's kind of like a college of
sorts so how many calls are you taking a
day like four that's not too bad and
they're like a half hour to an hour
let's not bad and I make content and I
just do whatever the [__] I want the
rest of the day but I don't even but you
don't enjoy it I didn't want to do
anything like at the end day I want to
have a steak well I just think enjoyment
or happiness is like uh
there's just no real point it's a Pecan
Valley I like like goodness is
uneventful it doesn't flash it it glows
you know so I I just like stay flat and
like are you crazy about diet yeah but I
I mean
look at that body [__] thing you know
but I I still eat something I like every
day you know I mean hey dude do you like
to work out it's my favorite term hey
[__] [__] faces if someone says [__]
face we're best friends today Ryan's
like what's up bro do you worked out
that's what I said to my buddy Kevin I
go uh yeah I'll be watching the game
[__] face so come on down
the best [__] word but um yeah the
whole I eat I eat something I like every
[__] day so I I'll usually eat
carnivore all day while I'm working me I
do see carnivore all day while I'm
working and a night before bed I'll have
some carbs I like I'll knock out like
what what kind of color I'll [__] eat
a whole [__] ice cream I don't know
whatever [__] I want right before bed
but if you did my math tougher brother I
didn't yeah if you did the [__]
macros to like way I eat it would be
less than what I a lot people in my
program yeah like it the numbers would
be less because you're clean all day I
just I clean all day like [__] just
all protein all day like two three
shakes even they're like the ones that
are like Whole Food shaped ones like the
RTD ones or something like that yeah and
then um and then like two like a bison
meal a chicken meal maybe a fish meal
and then some carbs I like before bed
the insulin Spike [__] makes you
sleep like a [__] baby it's a perfect
way of eating none of you guys should
eat that way you guys should consult a
professional who's gonna actually have
you drop the weight because most you fat
[__] think you could do that
and you can't you have to like attain
this [__] first but I'm looking at your
body I'll do what you're telling yeah
but it's not gonna work it's it's mainly
for maintenance and building a little
money yeah once you get there yeah once
you get there you can eat like that but
if I want to be better I'm gonna have to
remove that for a couple weeks and then
like and then actually reverse diet and
like actually to put on size and [__]
like that but I'm not really trying to
do that everything's about mindset to me
now and success and other people I live
for other people I don't [__] live
for me like if I think about you guys
all day and and my homies and my
followers and everybody I'm trying to
help I'm free from me but when I think
about me and my desires I'm just [__]
like so intense that I'll have to go get
it you know right well you have Jesus on
your arm yeah Jesus this is more like uh
good and evil but I don't know what I
believe in really I know there's a
higher power but I'm not saying I know
which direct religion it is I don't know
where do you do you see yourself in 10
years doing exactly the same thing oh
just whatever whatever I have to do even
if I lost everything and I was living in
a cardboard box I would still do all the
stuff outwardly for the world that I do
every day which is my YouTube Monday
Wednesday Friday on GP Penitentiary life
Wes Watson and then um on my Instagram I
wake up at 2 45 posted every morning
post my workout four every every day
seven days a week and then I post all my
like beliefs and everything I'm thinking
throughout the day I show my team
members winning so that they have an
opportunity to sign up and win too and
um that's just that's right all the
world I owe the world the answers I've
found on the hero's journey which was
was holy [__] I was a [__] bag doing all
this [__] that I thought would work it
didn't work this is what I found look at
my life now when I was angry and
resentful and [__] drug addict and
all this [__] end up in prison when I
was all these great things then I ended
up here and like just to live for other
people is my main thing I don't [__]
really like give a [__] everything was
easy for me I don't give a [__] about me
like do you read Joseph Campbell I mean
I I read Joseph Campbell like the hero's
journey in some of his books in prison
but um my main thing is like I don't
read anymore yeah I just kind of like
live it yeah just live it and I feel it
I sense it I go into stoic quotes and
stuff like that just to get get the
wheels turning and I start to like
create my own question question is your
mom and dad still living with your
grandma they actually do bro you didn't
get them out no they dude there's a
personal question they don't they don't
really does it for us some people's
parents won't take help you know they're
like yeah they're like stubborn well
they're just like no like he learned it
like we don't like I have a [__] 20
000 square foot like 15 bedroom I have
15 bathroom 12 bedroom home that's a
mansion that's amazing
Bellagio I literally like walk around
like they're by myself [__] yeah it's
like a mile from the beach too so it's
like the mo the craziest [__]
property parents won't take your room
there you made some money yeah I made
some change no they they don't they
don't they don't like to they didn't
really visit me in prison I mean they
wanted to so you have a complicated
relationship I love them to death but
they just won't take it they're cool as
[__] I have no problems with anyone like
resentment is like drinking poison
wishing the other person will die
everyone knows that it keeps you
stagnant [__] [__] I just don't do
low frequency [__] and they a lot of
people don't know how not to they've
been stuck in that pattern for so long
that like negativity and gossip is their
[__] I'm like it's an easy pattern
together have you ever had a sociopath
come to you for help like somebody who's
truly a serial killer I mean
do you think of yourself as a sociopath
I'm all that [__] I think everybody is
narcissistic a sociopath I think
everybody is everything we like label
someone as at some percentage yes a
degree like a degree some people are
more 100
um yeah but there are people who are
more empathetic naturally
uh zero empathy like towards like [__]
like I'm I think we're supposed to be
very selfish and that's what makes us
take care of people more so I'm like I
can't treat I don't want to feel
horrible so I have to treat Brandon so
good and given this outcome and I do so
because so I'll feel better yeah I don't
really ever think that we're is anyone
really that well I heard somebody saying
by the others
they were like they were like you know
people like say well you're a sociopath
you know you're a bad person and
somebody said however they were we were
talking about like you know people are
sociopaths to the one percent okay and
then they were like the guy was like but
wait a minute if I have a [__]
surgeon and he has to operate on my
spine
I don't want that [__] emotional
at all I want a mechanic I want a
mechanic who is looking at me like I am
something to fix not somebody he likes
he gets to know me in the you know
that's not what you want so there are
certain jobs where a sociopath is
probably in matter how could you call a
person one thing like we're all we're
awesome
we're a verb I'm everything I I'm I'm
the worst I'm the best on this I'm that
but I'm aware of it that's great and I'm
aware of it I choose my best traits yes
I love it I love that I'm capable of
[__] the most horrendous [__] you
could imagine and because a [__]
will not test my people out I don't
[__] care like I'm not if someone
tried to [__] with Brian and we were out
eating I'll murder the [__]
right there I won't even think twice and
a lot of these [__] in this world
couldn't even fathom that they would
just be like oh my God what's happening
I'd already had splattered the dude I'm
like God damn it Brian I'm going to
prison again [__]
that's your natural that's your I just
can't let people harm people so how do
you deal with like online hate where
like you can't control that I just
ignore the source you know I I if I'm
reacting to something negative online
that means I'm in a low frequency State
and I'm vibrating at that frequency so I
go oh Wes you're such a [__] right now
like you're really vibrating with that
lift yourself above so I really exist in
this high frequency state where
everything's laughable like life is just
laughable to me because I'm in such a
good place I'm winning yeah you know try
to argue with me oh I'm winning dude
what are you guys talking about yeah
right but um the whole point is is like
I'm gonna tell my wife I really do love
winning I really do look at life like a
high frequency or low frequency and so
like I am like the surgeon but I'm like
it's just a massive awareness inside and
I'm always just
dipping the scales and seeing where I'm
at and understanding how to get myself
to where I need to be I even gauge like
my sales on my business to that I feel
like if I'm not in a grateful State and
I'm actually in a state of entitlement
through the opposite of gratitude I will
not be like drawing in those sales and
everything that that I've done that's
successful so like the second I'm
operating in any type of negative low
frequency State I swear the sales just
stop but if I'm vibing high and loving
this moment I'm in love with life dude
the energy is just [__] just drawing
it in then everything just starts
raining on them I just pay attention to
all like because I mean Tess and
Einstein said that if you want to know
the secrets of the universe look and
think in terms of energy frequency and
vibration and once I started to read
quotes then I started I had so much free
time in prison I started to really like
dissect myself and see what was
happening during what times and how I
felt what was going on so I started
linking it to like like where I was at
what was going on and everything and
I've really like become in tune and
aligned with that quote that we can
actually that's when people say like
you're manifesting [__] or you're
drawing should enter law of attraction I
like live it through and through like I
I'm not I don't talk about it so much or
I do sometimes but I don't really like
base my whole [__] off that kind of give
people a system give them Little Gems
and they're like oh this does work so
they can actually live it and connect it
you know dig it it's [__] great
should do some current events what do
you think about it we keeping Less on
current events or do we keep let's keep
West here you got time I got time all
day my driver's out front he's wait I
told him to come in is that your mailbox
out there oh yeah some Maybach dude
Maybach
it's the new the new sick one yeah but I
mean you got to get the white interior
on that [__] so the lighting
hits on it good but we hadn't drove it
in so long it barely has like [__]
300 miles it never I barely even got it
smogged but um we I'm like let's try the
Maybach taser he's like I don't know bro
because rims are so small it gets on
rubber bands dude yeah and then um I'm
like should we drive the [__] Cullen
in because I have the rolls SUV I have
the Phantom everything and I gotta maybe
drive the cone and it's safer it's
raining now we're enjoying the Phantom
if it [__] if we hit it if we pop a tire
or something no but I'm like it's an
adventure [__] yeah be fun yeah I'm like
let's just have an adventure hi my my
roads rust pop the tire where do I get I
need I need a rose tire please
ran over the jar is the driver a tuxedo
or just normal she just is it all black
he's a little gangster you know all
right
is all black but he's not black
so I remember the whole Paul Pelosi
thing that's closest husband yep uh the
whole there was a conspiracy about how
everything happened this guy right here
I mean I still thinking rumors about
nothing I don't know it is interesting
though even they called I get some
questions still the car won't know
anything going on in the news at all all
right so so Nancy Pelosi's husband
Speaker of the House in okay for the for
the Congress for the Democratic they
live in San Francisco her she was out in
Washington DC her husband was in the
house he's an older man this dude breaks
into the house he has a hammer and
explosives husbands in his underwear the
cops come to the door like what are you
doing the one part it sucks like I get
in the head in the head it's funny
because the on the cop cam they go they
he has something in his hand he's like
put the put the hammer down the guy goes
um nope and then just hit some right
yeah yeah so he's attacking a crazy
husband so this is the call is weird
this is the Intruder actually breaking
the glass with a hammer to get in there
was a conspiracy that someone that the
Paul Pelosi actually knew this guy is
gay let him in yeah so that guy may tell
[__] like that there's probably a an
amount of truth to it correct the
mystery is a little bit of a mystery
yeah but especially politicians I don't
know anything about the story though I'm
not sure if we can so the 911 call is
papelosi talking to the 911 like oh
someone's hearing any of it yeah it's
weird because uh Pelosi's uh husband
he's yeah Paul he's just he's like uh
like someone's here I didn't I don't
know him but he's like he's waiting for
my wife yeah I'm like should we send
someone he's like uh which it sort of
makes sense if the guy's crazy and he's
just trying the guy told him hey you
alert the cops yeah but it's weird the
guy let him call the cops that's so
everything's weird yeah the whole thing
is weird yeah it's all dicey so that was
a weird call but this is the one I don't
know we're not gonna play it on arable
play for you guys this is where the cops
show up this body cam footage of the guy
the Intruder and Paul Pelosi papalosi is
one with the button-up blue shirt
uh no yeah and then hit something that's
a two on one he's got on him there
Brennan so there's a wrestling move from
there you want to square up this dude's
going to the pin you want to squirt oh
this guy's going away yeah what happens
if you go to prison you're from Frisco
you're going to join the coat any white
you're going to join the cocoa County
car what happens
yeah he would probably be a Jay cat
that's what we call it that's what we
call someone who's not normal they're a
j cat then they end up at the hot meds
block and they're on meds you know okay
but if you kill them if you kill a kid
in jail or anything you're [__] oh
yeah
so there's papelosi here she's holding
there's that intruder
and he's a hammer in his hand right here
this is the weirdest [__] [__] and
then
boom he hits him out he knocks him out
did you hear Paul Pelosi's snoring it's
[__] up
so it's a legitimate attack yeah yeah
why the [__] wasn't he going dude this
[__] weirdo's in my house
probably probably afraid to say the cops
are here trying to stay calm yeah yeah
man yeah he's 82 sometimes feel like
that can't even talking [__] they're all
yeah no I'm sure he's afraid the guy's
gonna hit him so he's just kind of like
oh yeah someone's here I don't know just
trying to like make sure crazy
[__] this guy's got a hammer
he's kind of a big guy himself I mean
big out of shape guy how crazy it though
even that guy like yeah he let him call
the cops B he answers them open the door
opens all weird everything's weird yeah
I don't know that's why I own guns so
you come to my house and I hear a noise
I'm gonna shoot you in your [__] face
he's married uh Pelosi who they should
have security
they have high level security that's
crazy how are they not like the most
yeah I can uh
this one's crazy I want to hear about
this but before you do it so let me ask
you this when when you what are the
things that get you [__] up in jail
what what has to be I say is anything
with kids so like if you have like uh
you know hit a kid pedophile like
there's there's people there's a lot of
any of the [__] chomo [__] like
that's what they're checking for when I
said Megan's Law they're checking to see
if you're if you're a child molester
yeah or if you have like but don't they
separate those guys so you guys can't
get to them but sometimes they they like
uh sometimes they would sneak through or
they didn't check in or this or that or
the cops put them through just so they
didn't like them you know they want them
to get whacked they should be and they
first thing they're gonna do is cut your
face all crazy so that you're marked you
know but they're gonna cut your face and
try to kill you too but I mean I've seen
times where they knew the guy was a
chomo and they're like hey this guy's
getting handled at yard you know good
and so yeah the thing is is like
everybody knows and he's like making his
coffee and everybody's like oh [__] dude
and then they go out to yard and they're
just having them do burpees and work out
and he's like you thinking he has these
new Buddies
and dude and everyone's like oh my god
dude this dude's gonna get [__] man
he's like come on boys you got his heart
rate going yeah they get his heart rate
pumping so that he's he's gonna die
quick yeah and he just jumps up on the
pull-up bar dude comes up behind him
just
cuts his under right under his [__]
right here his neck he just lays on the
ground and he's just starting I've seen
a dude pull out a Bone Crusher like like
10 inches that's what you call a huge
knife in prison and he just comes up
behind us we're like sitting next to him
he's grabs him by his neck and just in
his chest like a few times but I mean it
just was consistent yeah I mean I
remember this full Bobby uh from uh
Butte County gangsters BCG little white
boy
um they found out this whole dude see
the older dudes would slide through so
they'd be on a yard for a long time like
now it won't really happen as much but
like an old dude was on the yard for a
long time before they had phones before
they had Megan's Law before they checked
that ship and then he like gets shipped
to like a different joint and then
recheck the paperwork and then uh it was
pizza day and um Bobby's like I'll
[__] do it he wanted to be that dude
so he rolls up behind the dude just cuts
his neck cuts his face all crazy and he
didn't want to [__] up his nice shoes so
he was wearing State shoes which at that
place were the orange ones like the
orange state issued Chucks you know and
dumbass is caught on camera he's the
only one wearing these shoes and so he
gets caught on camera and he ends up in
the back and when I went back to be
sellies with swally the Asian dude Bobby
was still back there two years later
after the [__] damn and so he like had
the back back there but he he had been
back he had he was back in the back for
four years and uh he was signing to me
he's like Wes There's No Deal they're
not cutting me with nothing they're
giving me attempted murder and all this
[__] and I mean he wanted to be that
dude so he raised his hand but a lot of
guys in there will raise their hand to
do that because a lot of guys in there
were molested and [__] and we're [__]
and then they're all [__] up and I
don't know anything about that like I
grew up my dad was like a beast
construction worker my mom was normal my
family was normal there's no weird [__]
in my family yeah but a lot of these
dudes were like foster kids
yeah they were like abused and like
they're like you don't know why they're
like that but so like in some spots in
like Sacramento and like Kern County and
[__] they have whole clicks of people
that they get out of prison and they
just search for chomos and [__] on Megan
so they go [__] whack them wow and
it's like I mean I was I was locked down
the Lord's work yeah I mean just
literally like [__] like what needs
to be done and um these [__]
are they're they're with the business
you know it's like
they were hurt you know and their lives
are [__] up and they don't know how to
get past that like true trauma you could
see in their eyes
[__] torture children and they're
like 35 and 47 right now and 27 like we
can do something about this yeah yeah
they're gonna take their hang out on
that dude what's gotcha
there was something interesting about it
though because apparently there was a
Vice Lord this was a rumor a Vice Lord
put his guys in there so those guys used
to be part of a gang apparently they're
doing that yeah did you see that going
around they're doing like kits on other
gang members yeah like it's like it runs
deep man it runs deep CNN's trying to
make it a racist thing but boy are they
reaching here yeah they are it's all
black on black how is it racist I mean
they're saying the institution
systematic racism which don't make sense
here and they pulled them up for
reckless driving and then just just
[__] and yeah but they were going
after him because apparently the guy
look at those ones online where they'll
like handcuff all these guys to the
table yep like in a prison they're like
handcuff them to the table and like let
like some white dude out with a knife
and they're like what the [__] and
they're like the guy's like [__] okay
and they're in prison like dude there's
crazy [__] they think there's crazy [__]
I mean the [__] that goes on the street
is kind of like
it's wild man it's kind of like but just
to what goes on in prison and [__] like
it's so [__] like like I remember one
time they read they rushed the block
when we were in Donovan we were in 17
block and it was a four yard and this
was reception this right right out of
like right when you go from County Jail
you go to reception we start going to
yard and like I had like a kite of like
everybody's names and uh their charges
and all that [__] and um and I got
caught with it and the cops like and
this one copy just putting on his gloves
and he's like he's like I'm gonna check
in your [__] you know like I'm I'm a
[__] I'ma [__] you up you know and
I'm like what the [__] is I just fell I
just got busted I'm like the [__] is the
matter with you dude and the dude's eyes
are just like black circles and he's
just like so demonic I'm like why do you
even work here like what the [__] does
it matter it's off on it yeah like did
just later on I I would like joke about
it like they would check your [__]
when you're leaving to yard for like a
shoe or something you have to swat and
cough before you go out to the yard when
you're leaving the shoe you have to Cuff
up before you leave your show and I
would Squat and cough I back that's how
you know us all huh you don't even know
me by my face you know me about my
[__] huh I squawk my hey Watson there
you are yeah there's one hey who are you
is it they're just so sickening bro like
yeah the human want to do that yeah it's
a Power Trip yeah like who the [__]
would want that [__] job but they
want to see you don't have a shank in
your ass dude 100 and fools would like I
did this full chili when they first
rushed the block uh that time when the
guy Rodriguez was like I'm a [__]
look around I'm gonna [__] you up you
know and uh he was he had a 14-inch
knife hanging out his ass that's why
they were tripping 14 inches yeah
they're massive like he keeps a cork in
there don't you yeah 14 inches
[__] it'll be up into their stomach
Jesus Christ rapping with [__] can't you
do with a smaller knife that's a guy
who's like he like he's like I better
get that 14 inches up my ass just
because just to be safe six inches hey
chili how'd you sneak that machete
yeah why does it look like a dildo this
is weird why is Machete a big black Dill
has the handle look like a [__] because
dude hey I think Chili's we'll be
hooping his phone and not turn it off
and be on the yard and the yard goes
down and his chick starts calling and
dude's like dude I was getting the
biggest boner that [__] was like in my
ass vibrating vibration
and I got I'm like he's like I wasn't
even like thinking about no weird [__] I
was like stimulating my prostate yeah
man nothing you can do I'm gonna come
it's supposed to be a hooping like the
[__] big ass phones and [__] fat ass
[__] in prison just pull up
their belly flap put the phone a little
advantage on the back guys yeah the fat
guy's got that like that that guy's good
the cops will never check it I'm back
dude but how the [__] buddy like Buddy
Rogers your Vago and he's doing like 40
years you got kind of pushing some dope
when we were out of state and um so like
they send you the cocf California out of
State Correctional Facility when like
they run out of bed space in California
so then you go to like Oklahoma Arizona
all these [__] up States and it's like
California inmates in Oklahoma and like
we're out there just [__] running a
train on these cops that are not
literally but we're running a train on
these cops because they just don't get
how shits run yeah and they're like
Walmart employees that are like North
Fork Correctional Facility Sayer and
they just don't even get how anything
works and we're just like so much
[__] quicker than these [__]
two steps ahead we're like ordering
keyboards like like what we're like a
big ass keyboard and like ship it to
like a different [__] address have a
dude like put like 100 phones in there
like dope tobacco everything back hey
watching your third keyboard just showed
up I'm like oh yeah you get my keyboard
yeah where's your brother Watson yeah oh
yeah
oh yeah and they had like Xboxes and
like video games drones and drop [__]
like uh they do that that's like weird
[__] I've never seen that we ship [__]
in like you take apart [__] yeah drone
in the prison yeah
oh tennis ball full of coke Friday I
don't think they had drones when I was
in prison yes even if they did you
couldn't fly them over the prison and
drop [__] off oh no bro I run an outside
operation what are you really stupid
what do you shut up what are you uh what
do you uh put that knife in your ass
what do you uh crazy how long have you
been out five years
five years movie is all five weeks yeah
and I feel good although that's okay I
feel really good it's a [__] long
time I mean but that's the thing is
people think that they've changed and
like I became different in a good way
yes and like the whole thing is is like
it's gonna take a long time to
restructure who you are and I mean
people just don't get that the only way
you can do that is through your thoughts
and actions you structure your core
beliefs during times of adversity it
can't be during good times so the only
way you can change out here is
self-inflict adversity and then align
your thoughts and actions on who you
want to be on the other end so like a
fat [__] [__] will go into a
workout which is adversity to his fat
ass and he's just all oh this is so
difficult [__] I don't feel like doing
this now he structures core beliefs that
workout is not good for him it's [__]
difficult he doesn't like it and now he
becomes like more of a [__] and so like
when you're going through something
really difficult like them like I was on
lockdowns for over a year where you
didn't leave the cell like race show
lockdowns where white dudes are stabbing
white dudes and they just can't let you
guys out like there's problems and so
they're not letting anybody out and like
a huge Riot like they can't let anyone
out for a year you do not step out of
the cell for I do have lockdown in 2011
October and we didn't come out until
January 2000 we didn't get to the
sunshine I didn't walk out of the cell
no shower no nothing you you sit on the
toilet people going crazy you fill the
toilet up with sink water and you pour
it on yourself it's called a bird bath
and you soap up and you do it again and
do that multiple times a day while
working out multiple times in the cell
and like you're just chilling it was
almost more enjoyable than mobbing
around doing all this [__] but I mean
the point is is
like during those times or how I
structure the mindset I have the door
would close I say good [__] I'm
going to show you who I am when I come
out right and so that whole time my
thoughts were strong my actions were
affirming my thoughts and I would
structure your thoughts like you had oh
yeah always I I would everywhere around
my cell would have stuff written that I
wanted to like quotes from like
different stoics or just quote books and
I'd have something written like
everywhere so when I turned I had like
something that I I had to read that did
you sell me my mind did you sell mate
like that well I would just put up
different [__] on my calendar or
something and most of my Sally's had to
go with what I was saying I'm bigger
than most dudes in prison if you went to
prison they'd be like this dude's a
monster like there's very few big dudes
most dudes are strung out dope fiends so
like they're just like oh I'm just gonna
go with what it says like I'm and like I
would motivate them to work out I bet no
we're doing this cool yeah they're
pretty glad and I was like a cool dude
I'm not like some weirdo like you get
weirdo sillies like you're like God damn
look at this [__] weirdo like I got a
j cat I you beat the dog [__] out I'm
just that now a problem one time one of
my Sally's he was a his name was Steve
Young he was a [__] cat bro he's no
no but kind of but he just had that mean
weathered ass mug yeah that weathered
ass old ass white boy mug and um
he was from Ridgecrest like right by
Mammoth you know like one of them weird
little towns off the [__] 350
mountain towns Mountain [__] town
[__] weird [__] and um we were at the
chow hall and like the little homie uh
the little homie silent from SD he's
like hey hey Wes you want my eggs and
then Steve goes yeah I'll take him and
he just reaches over and eat cigs and
I'm like
I'm like you good big dog like you get
enough he's like yeah I got enough I
said okay okay and then someone else had
some [__] he jumped on that too and then
I'm like okay I'll see you when we get
back to the cell though he's like what
and he's like God is Mean Mug you always
try to have this mean mug we're getting
to sell my eye put him up [__]
and he's just like he went into one of
these because he was so old hell yeah
and I just walked over and I pulled his
arms down and just just domed him just
just [__] and he like hit the ground
harder than I hit him I had to sit him
up put him in his chair he's all shaking
and like the cops walked by they're like
what's going on there I'm like hey keep
on going and then [__] uh I just sit
him up in his chair and he wakes up he's
like what the [__] I'm like dude I
literally I'll [__] kill you dude
just sit the [__] down two weeks later
he starts cooking wine gets drunk he's
yelling in the vent all drunk and Buddy
shines down to me he's like hey your
cell is just a problem it's always just
keep being a problem yeah and so like
you get people like that why was that a
problem with trouble so if you have a
Celly like me who's cool and like you
could talk to like you're like [__] yeah
like I'm not gonna have to kill this
mother you're not a liability
why did you beat that guy up for wanting
more food because he wasn't like letting
me get a chance the guy asked me and he
jumped in till I get it and like it's so
disrespectful like when food is an issue
in prison it's like you just took
[__] food out my mouth dog you know
it needs his protein yeah and then then
uh then the time he gets drunk and he's
in the vent yelling and like the homies
signed over to Buddy they're like hey
have Wes handle that like you don't yell
in the vent you know people are sleeping
is that high level of respect in prison
and then so I just I go over you know I
put my blocker up in the window and I
just beat the [__] life out I'm just
pounding his head in on the [__]
ground forever and I just sit him back
up in his chair again I had so many
times I had to sit him back up in his
chair because there's a blocker right
here and it looks like he's watching TV
and I put his feet up and everything and
he would just be all just knock the [__]
out just Weekend At Bernies
he looked like Bernie he did cool was he
cool after that no no he kept having
problems man next time uh who the [__]
was that is discipline another kid had
to [__] him up again and that's when he
was finally uh not able to come back
they just let him go finally they
removed him but um this was over and
over and this is different sellies
different people many [__] times to
her social intelligence is important
they have no emotional intelligence they
can't read [__] no it's a sickness
nowadays yes
Shooters and [__] they've been
helicopter oh my God yeah shelter
what the [__] did your parents do to you
like you ever heard that expression
anti-fragile no no so the idea is is um
this book by Nasim taleb he wrote a book
called Enterprise which is like you're
so there's fragile and then there's you
know tough but you want to be
anti-fragile like the way you become
like your immune system is anti-fragile
because the more your immune system sees
pathogens and bacteria
and I feel like I'm like that because I
tell people I don't believe in sickness
I don't participate yeah yeah people
tell me that they're like you you never
take a day after you get sick I'm like I
don't participate it well your mind and
your spirit and your body can become
anti-fragile you're supposed to become
actual the more you stress test you
become inoculated the more you read this
book yeah it's a great book anti-fragile
[__] really good book man uh not see
until I'm he's a mathematician weird
thing but um when you turn the book
around does it look like he practices
what he talks about though that's a
problem yeah so he talks about that too
so so now he wrote a book called Skin In
the game and he said we're running our
country's being run by people who don't
pay a price for being wrong and he said
the thing about the like so that's why
he lifts weights and stuff he's like
this big guy and he's I always get so
mad when like he's a high level [__]
mouth competition we love Jordan
Peterson but what what right does he
have saying there he is he's always
talking about men and he's always
powerlifting he that he believes in
putting himself in positions but he's a
real intellectual but he [__] lifts
weights at least he's still lifting he's
always yeah at least he's lifted yeah
but what are we saying about Jordan
Peterson I mean I love Jordan Peterson
he gives me the chills he's so smart
he's educated me a lot but I mean God
damn what's he says I really feel like
he's disciplined and dangerous like does
he really feel like he is does he say
that I would say he is in the sense that
he's willing to put his beliefs I know
for the test no matter what like and men
have to be Savages
what is Jordan Peterson saying no he
just he just says like a man has to be
capable of
um extreme violence yeah but willingly
forego it and that's like a true like
the contrast of a of a man
what violence have you ever [__] done
no no and that's the thing it's like I I
love it
I would never disrespect Peterson
because he's done so much for me like
he's taught me so [__] yeah love the
[__] but I mean I just that's
what helped me is seen a lot of these
guys by like turn the book around is
that really is that guy really living
what he says and so when I wrote my book
I had to make sure that if you turn the
[__] book around I'm living what the
[__] I said is it you with your shirt
off no but like the front of my book is
a picture that I took in prison that the
cops were like
um take it's a Wes Watson a
non-negotiable ten years
um but I took that pick in prison the
cops were like take the [__] your
Instagram now I said no I'm this is
going to be covering my book one day
[__] and um like literally like
now they have to see that I have a
best-selling book that's made me [__]
Millions yeah that's cool and uh and I
took the picture in prison with the
[__] phone that they told me to get
rid of it that's cool that's a great
[__] picture well like not to you
know I'm not a Christian but Jesus
Christ the idea is you walk in his
footsteps do you you work with lepers
sell all your belongings [__] give
the money to the poor turn the other
cheeks and and when you get punched in
the face and tell that you're an enemy
you love him and mean it those things
are hard to do oh no
that's somewhat but in this world you
can't no I'm saying I'm saying that he
he walked the walk like yeah yeah it's
hard to walk I mean yeah they're
crucifying you and you're like I love
you still yeah exactly I really refer to
that a lot when someone is [__]
pissing me off for like usually a chick
problem or something like if something's
like really agitated me I'm like dude if
you that [__] was crucified and
and was saying I love you and I forgive
you and that that's true strength if you
can choose that high frequency emotion
yeah during like a time where you want
to choose something else that choice is
true strength strength is built to
restraint yes and I really truly know
that but I in a lot of the world is so
[__] now and everyone's so [__] weak
that I don't do them Justice by telling
them that because they'll already
restrain themselves so much I need them
to kick some ass too yeah like I need
them to be strong too because they are
so passive so weak and so timid because
everyone told them to not be too to make
sure you're humble did anyone tell you
not to be too timid passiving much of a
[__] like [__] that like they need to
tell people to not do that either yep
like there has to be both sides I think
we're good on current events Chad I
think so too yeah yeah I think he
crushed it we don't need current events
well time does it fit here you crushed
it I love talking to you on for a hot
second I can live here for [__] with
you I could Vibe here with you guys all
the time I love it yeah you're great I
like how I like how practical you are
about things I love the quotes you
brought up I'm gonna I'm gonna like pick
up those books too because I will never
read a [__] book until it lands on my
lap and my conscience tells me read it
yes read it read it yes and I have to
like it has to hit me like a few times
and that one like that's dope you know a
lot of reading can be a procrastination
right like a lot of you know the answers
you know what the [__] you're supposed
to say with your life but I do like when
I read something that puts things into
context and that's why I like Jordan
Peterson he reminds me of the old truths
the truths that seem to have lasted the
the value of old stories is that they've
been around a long time they have
something to offer for a reason that's
what I I like how I found what I believe
is infinite intelligence is through
quotes So I read quote books and I saw
that everybody was saying the same thing
since the dawn of time just in different
words and how could they all be saying
the same thing if there wasn't
centralized intelligence so I'm like
okay so there has to be something
speaking to us that's centralized I
don't know what the [__] it is to shape
the form or whatever and then I read
like um Napoleon Hill outwitting the
devil and he said the gateway to
infinite intelligence is through
gratitude so you know and then the the
contrast of that is you being in a
negative place and choosing gratitude
would be the greatest form of gratitude
and I was in a very negative Place
prison and I was just still choosing
gratitude so I felt like I was more of
like uh you know a chosen advocate of
this message so then I would be able to
tap into what were the [__] just that
that [__] infinite intelligence those
where you don't have to read anymore
those universal truth Universal truths
that you don't have to read anymore like
number one is is um like the law of
divine Oneness that's the first
universal truth a lot of divine Oneness
so we're all connected so like I have to
treat Brendan as well as I treat homie
right here in in my boy right here and
everybody so like a lot of people just
took out for their people but they're
not realizing that we're all connected
and so that's why Transcendence is key
to where like you guys have you guys are
doing it but everybody all you
successful [__] out there
who've got some type of success you need
an outlet like you can't just stay in a
phase of self-actualization where you're
like trying to be the best you forever
you have to to become actualized you
actually have to transcend self so it's
self-transcendence is happening yeah
giving it to other people you'll never
be free until you learn to do that and I
mean that was like the whole point of
everything I did which was
Joseph Campbell hero's journey take
everything I learned bring it to
everybody and just unbiasedly share it
wow because think about the book of five
rings okay I don't know if you ever read
it no you're dropping heat now I'm like
you've dropped so much good quotes and
everything you got me like wanting to
research books you've got to read me a
month he he was the first Samurai to
fight with two swords you know he was
the baddest [__] on the planet
and he what happened was in Japan was at
Civil War for 300 years and he was a
ronin which was a Shogun who was a like
owned a certain part of Japan would hire
mercenaries and he was in a battle and
he hid under some dead bodies because he
was afraid he was a coward and he
couldn't live that down and so he
decided he would become the greatest
Samurai you know and and he wrote a book
called The Book of five rings that gave
me the children he said decided he would
become he would become and and [__]
he goes so deep Rogan talks about this a
lot too like he he he
you being a high level comedian when
someone decides I'm gonna be great
that's it that's what I care about like
life you see that in your in your mind's
eye and he talks about practice and deep
practice and how practicing on a level
where it's kind of life and death
because there's no [__] you don't you
don't play sword fighting and you don't
walk away from a sword fight you know
especially that [__] and he talks about
like that he even says in the book he
says a lot of times you see Perry people
say I got this and I got that he goes
sword fighting isn't that way it's
actually that it's the first person who
you know who gets there first that's how
final it is but he talks about deep
practice he talks about living that
Razor's Edge right and he lived an
extreme life like a complete true
samurai bushida way of the warrior life
in every way he's got 21 rules of the
Samurai have no fear of death all that
[__] but what's interesting about all
that is when he finally had 60 fights
and and became this feared Samurai open
to school and then he wrote a book and
what was interesting about the book is
that he wanted to give back what he had
learned about how the universe works he
said there is there is a way the
universe works and it comes from
difficulty practices
it's just [__] lit I mean that's when
you get the chosen that's the
confirmation
but that that sort of thing is uh my my
whole program is teaching people to
transcend themselves and so like when
you wake up in the morning that's a
gratitude for life to show to just wake
up and to create the best you before
everybody's up yes like the best version
of you and the workout is to um to true
the actually the reading and reflection
and the journaling like just to really
um to to take that and give it to the
world like it's the intent to distribute
what you learned that morning in that
space each day and then the workout is
to get that positive mental attitude
that heightened rate of vibration to
bring that energy to everybody so like
if you didn't separate from stresses
bills life all these things that keep
you low frequency you didn't get to that
flow State you didn't really separate
from everything and become that better
version of self to be able to bring your
best self to everyone everybody Jim's
one of the only places people hold the
door for everyone when they're leaving I
mean it doesn't happen at the bank you
know so if someone wants to sign up for
your program where can they do it uh Wes
watson.com they just go there sign up
freaking FaceTiming you yeah yeah so um
Wes watson.com sign up and you it'll
text my phone and I actually do all my
sales okay come to me a year from now
chat with tattoos
oh there it is right there West Watson
yeah I have one of my website's very
efficient like to where when you click
it in 30 seconds you'll get a text me at
the same time and you're actually
texting me back and forth
I've done all my sales through uh
through text like that that's great man
Wes Watson thanks brother we appreciate
you brother yeah thank you guys [__]
great I mean I'm gonna be you're going
to have me reading again like I'm like I
got something I love it I never [__]
read but like when something really
strikes oh Brian a ton of references uh
I'll be winning in Springfield Missouri
uh Friday Saturday Blue Room comedy
February 3rd and 4th that's this Friday
Saturday uh next Saturday Austin will be
out there doing a fight campaign with Mr
Rogan Naples Florida February 16th
through 18th Bakersfield California one
night only have things almost sold out
February 23rd and then Brea I'm doing
fight command March 4th so we just did
two shows March 3rd that's a Friday
night only in Brea California get your
tickets at thickboy.com or fatkz.com B
Edmonton Alberta uh comic strip Canada
I'm coming it's been a while man
February 23rd 24th 25th Nashville
I got some time off I took some time off
good playing with my baby the best it's
good for [__] best keep going March 2
3 and 4. New York New York Sony Hall
March 11th come get some in West Nyack
New York the weekend after that Levity
Live March 16 to 18. Wes Watson's
opening for me the whole time he will be
there I'm gonna be there you can feel
those muscles and run your fingers
through his beard bless you're the best
brother what's watching everybody
that was awesome yeehaw